harvey's catastrophic devastating
flooding is just the latest chapter in
houston's long history of floods
tropical storm allison back in 2001
caused nearly 5 billion dollars in
damage the memorial day floods of 2015
dumped almost 12 inches of rain in 10
hours and last year 1200 people were
rescued after a flood on tax day chief
weathercaster lonnie quinn of our new
york station wcbs joins us once again to
explain why flooding is such a big
problem down in houston lonnie good
morning oh good morning to you maurice
look there are just so many factors at
play here none of them good first thing
you got to look at is the elevation of
houston now the city it's relatively
flat and it's barely above sea level
downtown houston is only 50 feet above
sea level so that means when rain falls
it has nowhere to go and it takes a long
time to drain out now some experts are
also pointing a finger at houston's big
building boom as a potential factor here
in exacerbating the problems and no
doubt it has because the development has
decreased the amount of wetlands in the
city
you ready for this by 50 over the last
25 years so the more pavement you have
that means there's less land to soak up
the rain after a major rainstorm and in
fact the number of downpours look at
this fact
downpours of at least 10 inches or more
have doubled have doubled over the last
30 years so when a slow-moving storm
like hurricane harvey hits the city
flooding can and as you can see here is
intense the bayou system holds the key
houston's buffalo body reached a record
69-foot crest in one area yesterday now
in houston the bios handle two inches of
rain per hour without having big
flooding but on site on saturday the
rain rate was up to eight inches per
hour so you can see how that flooding
just happened so quickly all over the
area and with more heavy rain over the
next two days more flooding is
yeah i hate to say it is unfortunately
very likely it's going to happen so that
means houston's flooding concerns are
far
from over margaret thank you lonnie